يبدو الأمر وكأن المرء ينظر إلى
دمية مروعة من حياة محطمة تتساقط أجزاء
من الخرسانة حيث يحاول الناس
تنظيف أو إنقاذ ما في وسعهم
وسط الأهوال التي لا يستطيعون الهروب بها من
إيما تمامًا مثل هذا المألوف لدينا
قبل عام من الحصار  حلب ولكن
هذه مدينة أدلب ، حيث كان من
المفترض أن تكون العائلات آمنة ، وكان من المفترض أن يكون
ملجأ واحدًا من آخر ما تبقى
جزءًا مما يسمى منطقة خفض التصعيد
التي أصبحت مؤخرًا أي شيء
سوى الضربات التي ضربت  حدث هذا
قبل خمسة أيام من وصولنا والعديد من الذين
التقيناهم قد فروا بالفعل من حلب ، وكان
الرأس سيكون محظوظًا جدًا لأنهم كانوا في
تلك الغرفة الخلفية ، لكن هوكابي
مسكون بكل ما فقده زوجته التي
قُتلت في حلب قبل ست سنوات  إنه
يربي ولديه بمفرده ، وسأل عن
مكان الأولاد الآن وعيناه
ممتلئة بالدموع
[موسيقى]
كان الصبيان يدرسان للامتحانات
عندما هزت القنابل المبنى
وامتص الهواء من الغرفة وذهب كل شيء
عندما كان الأطفال
أصغر سناً خلال الأوقات السعيدة ،
نتجه جنوباً حيث تشعر بعض البلدات بالفعل بأنها
مهجورة ، وكانت ميريديث ونورما
أقرب إلى الخطوط الأمامية
للأطفال المقاتلين يفتشون في
أعقاب القنابل للبحث عن البلاستيك
لبيعه لك.  نختبئ من القنابل
التي يقولون إن النظام السوري
وداعميه الأجانب الأخيرة تهدف
إلى القضاء عليه أو على الأقل
خنق آخر
معقل رئيسي للمعارضة ، كان مئات الآلاف من
الأشخاص في حالة تحرك خلال
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ،
فر العديد منهم قبل ما  إنهم يعلمون أنهم
قادمون أو بمجرد أن ضربت الضربات الأولى ،
يعيش البعض في مخيمات مؤقتة على
طول الطريق إلى تركيا ، وبذلك يجلبون كل ما في
وسعهم بما في ذلك ماشيتهم
الآن ، الجميع مستسلم لعلم
أنه لن ينقذهم أحد
ولن يتوقف أحد  العنف كانت رادها
وعائلتها في البداية في أراضي داعش
منذ أكثر من عام حيث كانوا يفرون
هناك ، حيث وقع انفجار قالت ابنتها
إنه  كادت أن تفقد ساقها ولا أحب
أن أتذكر أن الفتاة البالغة من العمر سبع سنوات تخبرنا
أنها اعتقدت أنها ستكون بأمان ولكن بعد
ذلك بدأ النظام والروس في
القصف وقبل أربعة أيام وصلوا إلى
هنا
تقوم منظمات الإغاثة التركية ببناء المزيد من
القديم والتوسع.  المخيمات في
سوريا مقابل حدودهم ، أنا
أملي أن أصغر محمد ولد
في المخيم في اليوم الذي وصلوا فيه ، أرى
فكرة
أن المناطق المتمردة المتبقية في سوريا تخاطر
بالتحول إلى حلب التالية فقط هذه
المرة حتى أن عددًا أقل من الناس يشاهدون
ويبدو أن القليل منهم يهتم  بالنسبة للكثيرين الذين تحدثنا إليهم
هنا ، فإن الأمر لا يتعلق بما إذا كانت هذه المنطقة
ستُقصف أيضًا ، فالأمر يتعلق بموعد
وعدد الأرواح التي يمكن سحقها في
الفضاء الآمن المتقلص وماذا يحدث
عندما تختفي
Arwa Damon CNN ad lib Syria